[Music]  the entire time I knew him he only ever  had one goal to wipe out half the  universe if he gets all the Infinity  stones she can do it with the snap of  his fingers just like that tell me his  name again Santos  [Music]  we got one advantage  she's coming to us  we have a dance once so that's what we  use  [Music]  let's talk about this plant ears I think  it's good except it sucks so let me do  the plan and that way it might be really  good  Wow  in Izmir  dun dun  [Music]  half of humanity will still exist  perfectly balanced  as all things should be  I hope they remember you  [Music]  I'm Peter by the way dr. strange Oh  using your made-up names then I am  spider-man  [Music]